well the man facing charges in the death  of a local investigative reporter  arrested and appeared in court this  morning for a bill hearing former Clark  County public administrator Robert  Tellis was denied bail police say he  murdered reporter Jeff chairman in early  September tells public defender argued  that he does not pose a threat to the  community the state argued that since  Telus is facing life in prison he is a  Flight Risk  in this case the safety of the community  argument  Mr Telus is a danger to Noah the  evidence in this case is overwhelming  group is evident presumption is great  according to the Constitution  and our statutes he is not entitled to  bail at this point the DNA Telus will  remain detained without bail